London mayor Sadiq Khan has finally
spoken out about his City's growing
crime problem and here's what he said he
said there's no place for crime in
London but we can't arrest ourselves out
of the problem from removing knives from
our streets to providing young londoners
with meaningful and engaging activities
I am committed to being tough on crime
in its complex causes but he's obviously
not committed to that because he's
saying you can't arrest yourself out of
the problem and I'm here to tell you I'm
not I don't have a PhD in criminology
you can just arrest them if you arrest
the criminals then they will stop
stabbing and robbing people on the
street
I never crime to go down you need the
arrests to go up and then after you the
arrests go up you got to prosecute them
and put them in prison